the partial government shutdown is now
three weeks old and tomorrow it'll
become the longest in US history federal
workers who are not being paid are
starting to hold protests around the
country the shutdown began over
president Trump's demands for billions
of dollars for a border wall Paula Reed
is at the White House where the
president has returned from a visit to
the southern border Paula good morning
good morning the president's trip to
Texas was part of an all-out offensive
to build a border wall but he has made
no progress with lawmakers over the past
several days and it appears that his
only realistic option may be to sidestep
Congress yesterday he appeared to be
laying the groundwork to do just that
saying he is willing to declare a
national emergency if we don't have a
barrier if we don't have a steel or
concrete barrier we're all wasting a lot
of time as hundreds of thousands of
federal workers prepare to miss their
first paycheck today President Trump is
at war over his wall everybody wants us
to win this battle it's common sense
death is pouring through deliberately
surrounded by helicopters and contraband
seized by border agents the president
continued to portray the nation is under
siege by gangs drugs and human
traffickers they need a barrier they
need a wall but federal workers need to
put food on the table we need our
paychecks across the country
increasingly desperate federal workers
staged protests against the shutdown
even the president's most ardent
supporters see no end in sight for the
standoff I have never seen more
depressed about moving forward them
right now I just don't see a fast way
for a key issue for Republicans the
president's mixed messages on who pays
for the wall he told this to John
Dickerson three months after taking
office
yesterday the president took a different
approach obviously they're not gonna
write a check but they are paying for
the wall indirectly many many times over
by the really great trade deal we just
made if Democrats won't give him
taxpayer money for the wall the
president says he will exercise his
power to declare a national emergency I
would say it would be very surprising to
me that I would not declare a national
emergency doing so could allow the
President to use unspent Pentagon funds
to begin construction of the wall but in
the immediate future it would likely
keep lawyers a lot busier than
construction workers Democrats have
vowed to file legal challenges if the
president attempts to sidestep Congress
and even if the president prevailed at
the Supreme Court he would likely face
another round of legal challenges from
property owners along the border bianna
and Paula thank you there's a Wall
Street Journal report out talking about
the infighting within the White House
and then about whether or not he should
declare this an emergency
not just to remind people the
president's policy as it was written
down on his website in detail the first
thing Mexico will pay a down payment on
the wall so when he says he wasn't
asking Mexico to pay by the details of
his campaign he was axe asking Mexico to
write a check yeah you remember that
exchange when you talk I do yeah I do
now that was when he was president right
and they were chanting build the wall
and he said absolutely Mexico's gonna
pay for and they're gonna be happy to
pay for it he said such confidence you
know we're about to set a government
shutdown record that nobody should be
proud of exactly